here's a look at all the exciting royal
things coming up in 2019
while 2018 was the year of royal wedding
2019 is all about baby fever
of course Will and Kate welcomes their
third child Prince Louie
last April but it's the upcoming arrival
of Megan and Harry's first babe sometime
this spring that were currently over the
moon about this pregnancy is probably
common as much of a happy surprise to
the couple as it has to ask the rest of
the world if you do the maths in terms
of the pregnancy it's likely that Megan
would have conceived probably towards
the middle or end of July and that's
just two months after they got married
so this is really very very quick no
surprise there both Harry and Megan have
been open about wanting kids for as long
as we can remember I can't wait for the
day what children's book can you not
wait to share with your kids the giving
tree' will start found me
the mom-to-be has been showing off and
cradling her growing bump in every
opportunity since announcing her
pregnancy in October but before baby's
Sussex makes its debut Harry and Megan
plan to move opting to ditch their
London residents at Kensington Palace
for the countryside of Windsor Castle
according to our source the construction
underway is taking place with the hopes
it will be livable and move-in ready
before the baby comes this spring and
speaking of royal cherubs were also
eagerly awaiting Prince Louie's first
official outing so far we've only gotten
a post birth Pete on his christening day
and in photos otherwise 2019 will be a
quieter one on the personal front for
Louie's parents Will and Kate sure
they'll attend events Commonwealth Day
and st. Patrick's Day are a few of the
festivities coming up early this year
and their two older kiddos are staying
busy with a new
hobbie George still loves its mother
a royal source tells ET that Princess
Charlotte has been taking private ballet
lessons - at a dance school in South
London plus we can't wait for the
three-year-olds first day of primary
school picks
rumor has it she'll join her big brother
at Thomas's Battersea in London but
pirouette son playdates aside were not
expecting anything major from the
Cambridge fam then there's Prince
Charles who since his 70th birthday in
November has been transitioning into a
more king-like role he'll spend the year
ramping up appearances and travel both
with and without Camilla
but the 92 year old Queen Mum isn't
slowing down yet in May Queen Elizabeth
is expected to attend the Windsor annual
Horse Show
we know she loves her ponies and of
course there's the Chelsea Flower Show
amongst her appearances in June London
will come to a halt in honor of her
Majesty's 93rd birthday
aka trooping the colour
where she'll make her annual celebratory
balcony appearance this will most likely
be Louie's first but back on the Sussex
front it's a new chapter America and
Canada get ready
from Meghan in Harry's royal offspring
later this year there would be the
adventure of a lifetime
according to royal expert Katie Nichol a
possible fall tour for the trio is in
the very early stages of planning also
on the Sussex fall agenda Prince Harry's
35th birthday we can't wait to see the
celebration he has in store like the
rest of us the royal families out the
year with the holidays and of course
another Christmas morning a dress made
by the Queen herself for many the
service of nine Lessons and Carols from
King's College Cambridge is when
Christmas begins let's hope she loses
the clunky gold piano this time around
and that concludes our royal predictions
for 2019
[Applause]
[Music]